[Music]
hi drew my name is simone and i am in my
hometown of baltimore maryland i love
baltimore because it has so much history
so much beauty but the thing i love most
here is the food scene i'm a food
vlogger here in the area so i just post
all the best eats and drinks in
baltimore so i want to show you around
um to some of baltimore's most fun and
exciting and delicious foodie
destinations
first stop is belvedere square market
say hello to my friends at nepal savory
smokery in general they sell all kinds
of smoked goods but neil paul sells my
favorite sandwich in baltimore
they're salmon blt and their famous new
zealand smoked mussels these are a must
try here in baltimore
for dessert ice cream from prego family
creamery mandy here is going to help us
out they are a family-owned creamery
right outside of belvedere square and
they have a farm out in the county but
they make their ice cream fresh
every day my cameraman here got their
strawberry ice cream with sprinkles and
a cherry on top
last stop at belvedere square market is
tasha flowers i come to tasha to get my
bouquets for my living room kitchen
bedroom for the week so we're going to
grab this asiatic lily here because look
at that it is perfectly open that's just
a little peek of belvedere square market
now moving on to our second stop welcome
to chat hour at good neighbor coffee
shop
we'll have some very creative appetizers
great conversation
[Music]
our third stop is here on the water
welcome to the baltimore water taxi
sunset cruise here you bring your
favorite snacks and drinks and cruise
along the inner harbor watching the sun
go down and just the beautiful skyline
of baltimore
well drew that's just a small look at my
beautiful city of baltimore i hope you
love it as much as i do and i hope to
see you here soon bye
[Music]